as many states slowly begin to reopen
for business companies are ramping up
production of antibody tests now these
are tests that can reveal whether a
person previously had the corona virus
this week the FDA authorized a test from
a Swiss company with near 100% accuracy
so let's get our doctor David agus in
here he's gonna join us from Los Angeles
with what we can learn from these exams
and if they're reliable dr. agus good
morning so an antibody test how does it
work and how do you see it being used so
when something foreign comes in your
body your body makes proteins called
antibodies that actually take it out of
circulation and so this is a test where
they take either a tube of blood or a
drop a blood here here's the kid
actually where you can take a drop of
blood and it's put into here and there's
a filter paper that filters out the red
cells and then it says our antibodies
proteins that are targeting Koba 19
present are their exposure so were you
exposed to the virus that's the what
anybody test tells you were you exposed
to the virus and is it is it accurate
and and if you get an accurate answer
what do you do with it I mean is it
valuable information well that's the key
question so accurate is that there are
hundreds of tests literally out there
what we know from several studies is
that many of them are not accurate they
look at other coronaviruses so for
example if you had that common cold it
can come back positive mistaking that
for coronavirus or Kovan 19 the Roche
test that was approved this week he is
accurate it tells you whether you've
been exposed but what it doesn't say is
whether you have immunity whether you
have the right antibodies to actually
take the virus and not let it get into
the body so that's what we call immunity
so it's very different to say you've
been exposed then you have immunity two
separate things sometimes I mean
obviously they can go together but the
tests now all of them just say whether
you've been exposed and again I can't
emphasize enough many of the tests on
the market are not accurate and they
will give you the wrong answer and that
worries me if I tell you that you've
been exposing you really haven't and you
go out and you don't social distance you
come home and you hug grandma you can
actually get her sick and that
worries me so bottom line dr. Davis
would you recommend regular people
people like me I was considering getting
an antibody test you can find them
online should people get them if they're
available so Tony your regular that's
what I'm trying to understand here they
know but clearly is that there is no
reason to get a test at the present time
unless you're part of an epidemiologic
study your company wants to know how
many people potentially have been
exposed so for reasons like that they're
important for personal decisions right
now they are not to be used because they
do not tell you immunity and so the key
going forward is to have that immunity
test they've been talking about it for
many weeks at the press conferences the
president holds I hope and pray it comes
soon all right dr. David agus I will
take your advice I'll hold off on the
antibody test now and for the record yes
I am regular I am everyday people thanks
for joining us